[Music]
as long as prosthesis have been around
people have been really focusing on
making it look like a hand and move like
a hand but our hand is not just a
grabber a hand is a touch
his touch that engages you with the
world is touched that engages you with
people a prosthesis without touch is a
tool that giving touch we're giving back
a hand I worked in a factory setting
before I lost my life I was doing some
cleaning under out from underneath a
shredder type machine and I'm grab
material that was in my hand and pulled
my hand into the machine I didn't think
that I'd ever have the sensation of
touch or anything back again and then my
prosthetics told me about the research
program up here in Cleveland they hope
to be able to give me the sense of touch
[Music]
the research that we've been doing is
reconnecting the man to the machine
basically learning how to take what the
prosthesis feels and translates that the
person using it feels it for the brain
to feel touch as being their actual hand
is really important that we activators
stimulate the wires that the brain
always used to get from the hand
what we do is we implant cuff electrodes
and then we apply really tiny amounts of
current that activate those wires and
that information then goes to the brain
so we've been learning how to place this
information on that nerve so the brain
thinks it's his hand they can feel not
just buzzing but also a touch of
pressure like somebody putting a finger
on their hand and in fact we've been
able to see that intensity of the
artificial stimulation mimics the intact
hand so big blow the first time they put
sensation on everything it was just
incredible it was like wow it could
actually feel an area in my hand a
certain area tingling and vibrations and
stuff small soft block I said just an
incredible feeling
bringing the prosthetic home with the
sensory hand on it and being able to
feel and everything's changed life
considerably it's just little things
that people take for granted brushing
teeth to be able to hold the toothpaste
and be able to squeeze and tell how hard
I'm squeezing this I don't squeeze and I
go every place it makes it a lot easier
we're at the point where subjects can
use their prosthesis at home they can
have sensation while they're at home it
makes them two-handed again it brings
back their hand and makes them whole
[Music]
Musha La Salette and she was 2 years old
from landmine
I thought that I should do something for
her dr. Turk I Chi roquette is working
with the world's first elephant hospital
located in Thailand since it opened more
than four thousand injured and sick
elephants have been treated I'm the
first one who invented the artificial
leg for the elephant
[Music]
using his knowledge as an orthopedic
surgeon dr. touch I designed musha's
artificial limb when she was just a baby
accounting for the elephant's weight and
size as she is grown pressure on the
prosthetic has increased causing it to
break so a new one is created every few
years this is a challenge for me too
every time we fix admit you improve it
this must study stronger please know in
the textbook sometimes try an error when
she obeys me careful can be and she know
where the candy she use her trying to go
into the pocket she know
I did operation on her food of 15 years
ago but can she remember me she liked to
come closer to me she showed a sigh of
salute our happy
at least means so much for her she can
lead normal life as she should be
[Music]
[Applause]
shipshape hi guys hi bubbles hi Walter
hey dolly hey mama
hi baby hi Albie Jenny's farm didn't
start out with animals that were missing
limbs it just happened to come to her
farm and she felt well prosthetic
technologies helped me it could
certainly help them I can't imagine not
having an artificial leg because I lost
my leg at ten and I'm quite used to it
it's thanks to medical science that I'm
able to live this normal life and for
these animals
I want no different for them hi Felix
what goes on it Woodstock Farm Sanctuary
on daily basis we're home to right now
around 300 rescued farm animals they've
all come from bad places and they get
the veterinary care the health care that
they need on a daily basis he's feisty
can you come help me with Felix they're
all actually in the front pasture little
Felix came to us as a as a baby lamb and
he had come from a big sheep farm and
overnight some sort of predator had
gotten in and they found little Felix
with his leg chewed off and so I spoke
to my prosthetist the gentleman who
makes my legs Erik many clinicians would
have went out to the farm I don't have
any experience with fitting prosthetics
on animals very few people in the
country do so I figured if I could take
what knowledge that I do have and apply
it to the animal like
we get them to utilize a prosthesis and
it wasn't until we got hooked up with
SUNY New Paltz and their 3d printing lab
that we were able to make something
pretty cool and cutting-edge for him
seeing him walk on the leg was
absolutely amazing from my limited
interactions with him he isn't
necessarily the most outgoing sheep in
the world it's actually very sheepish
but what he ended up doing was he
started running away from us which was
amazing
we were just jumping for joy that he
could actually get up and run keep up
with his flock he looked like he was a
very happy sheep if we could do this
more on other animals we wouldn't have
to you know put them down most of the
world doesn't fully understand it they
think of them as just farmed animals but
we hope that that changes and that's
part of the magic of what we do here
they get pastures to roam in access to
the Sun and to the grass they live life
the way they were intended to live
there's no greater joy
[Music]
when I was a kid I always played with
Legos I built cars planes motorbikes but
now I built an arm
[Music]
meet David Aguilar my name is David
Aguilar
I am from Andorra and I'm 18 years old
when David was born his right arm hadn't
fully developed this is the my right arm
growing up it was quite annoying because
I received a lot of commentaries like oh
you don't have a hand or something like
that and while some would see this as a
disadvantage
David is just a regular kid he likes EDM
he goes by the name hand solo get it he
has an embarrassing dad he goes to
school this is my school and he can open
doors with his Lego arm so cool growing
up he was obsessed with Lego so much so
he wanted to make it a part of him
literally I build my first prosthetic
arm when I was 9 years old and I build
it around my hand
it started being a boat unfortunately
the Lego bricks weren't strong enough
and it wasn't for another nine years
till he would try again this is mk1 this
is LEGO Technic it's like the
sophisticated part of Lego I can do
push-ups with this thing so it's quite
strong when I first build the arm and it
was fully functional I went to the
mirror
and I was like that model the mk1
only took five days to build of course
like any good adventure he got straight
to work on an upgrade and this is mk2
it has a battery that works like a
biceps and it has this fishing cable
that ties up in here when I fix this to
my shoulder I can do this and the arm
closes I can stop in the middle and move
it by myself
when I first brought this they were all
really amazed because how can somebody
create a hand out of Legos I was a
normal guy and when I build the yarn
everyone was like you're awesome you're
you're really smart they told me they
are really proud to be to be my friends
it's amazing it's not every day that
you'll see an amputee walking along with
a peg leg and then begin to tap-dance my
name is Evan Ruggiero and I am a
one-legged tap dancer
it's fun I sort of tap dancing when I
was six years old it's something that I
fell in love with
I knew that tap dancing would always be
something that I wanted to do for the
rest of my life when I was 19 years old
I had a pain in my right leg I was
diagnosed with osteosarcoma bone cancer
and on May 21st 2010 I had my right leg
amputated above the knee I was
devastated
I just thought having a tap dancer be
diagnosed with cancer in his leg
I remember my tap teacher showing me
footage of peg leg Bates who was a great
tap dancer way back in the day you know
had it not been for that footage I would
have never thought that I could tap
dance again
[Music]
when I put that pegleg on for the first
time and I started making those rhythms
I felt a part of me that came back and I
felt like my old self I was able to
teach myself how to dance again I just
let muscle memory kick back in and I
tried not to think about making a step
hop step with my peg leg with just peg
hop peg and changing around the
vocabulary of the step I performed in
New York City
there's definitely been an audible gasp
in the audience once or twice while I
walked out on stage tap dancing is a
very personal it's very much about the
emotion a lot of times you can tell when
a tap dancer is happy by the way he's
dancing despite having a diagnosis with
cancer I was able to overcome that and I
was able to go back to the things that I
loved the most
so it's always gonna be a very different
emotion that is tied to the artform
you
[Applause]